good afternoon
welcome to our daily press briefing
online and live on ebs
today is friday 18th of december
before moving to your questions as usual
we have a few announcements
uh to make first of all uh
who has good news on our efforts to
support europe's recovery from the
crisis
marta
thank you eric effective commission
politics facility
um
today we are pleased to announce that we
have selected 38
of europe's most promising startups and
smes to receive 176 million euros
from the european innovation council
accelerator the companies come from 18
countries
and their innovations range from rapid
detection of sepsis
to indoor plant lightning and hazardous
waste treatment by robotics
21 of the supported companies 21 of the
supported companies are led by a female
ceo
a woman each company will receive a
grant of up to 2.5 million euro
and half of the beneficiaries so that is
19 will also get the direct equity
investment from the newly established
eic fund
following this successful pilot the
european innovation council will be
fully launched next year on the
horizon europe and as always with more
information for you in
a daily news item thank you very much
johannes with this we are ready to take
your questions
and i passed the floor to odile
way bonjour
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
vote
i hope you hear me today yes i have a
related question because i noticed that
the
commission presented the issue the
statement yesterday saying
indeed that's a big difference is still
in particular when it comes to fisheries
and people don't understand why and i
would like to ask you if you could
explain
because i would think that both uk and
they will share the same concerns about
overfishing
in the seas and oceans so my question is
especially
will the uk continue let's say to comply
with this special
eu regulation on illegal
unregulated unreported fishing which is
so important let's say
to to prevent overfishing
is that an issue or which
which is difficult to solve
i would say i think that there are many
issues that are difficult to solve
in the in the question on fisheries um
i think nobody is contesting the fact
that there are going to be changes
after the end of the transition period
once the uk leaves the single market on
the customs union
what we are working hard on right now is
to find a new solution for a future
partnership
with the uk that can provide a
sustainable
um a sustainable solution in fisheries
and
all other questions by the way when it
comes to our economic partnership
our our security partnership when it
comes to internal security
amongst other things but obviously
you'll understand that i can't now go
into
the nitty-gritty of what our colleagues
are are discussing right now in the
negotiating room
down the road
thank you verena
you have an issue with your mic source
today it seems
can you hear me now yes yes super
thanks sorry for that um i'm very
nervous hoffman with the german press
agency
and then maybe you could help me in
interpreting the
um dictum of the final hours
um is the sunday deadline
set by the european parliament accepted
by
the negotiating team thank you
irena i i fully understand your your
interest
in deadlines of course i'm not going to
comment on that right now you know that
we're working hard
to reach an agreement again we're
perfectly aware that
the uk will leave the single market in
14 days time
we're all aware of the time constraints
but of course we're going to continue
working towards a deal and that's all
that i can say right now
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
conversation
catherine hello
try again
yes
very odd anyways um so a few little
questions
uh from the president's
uh presentation to the parliament
earlier in the week uh i was given the
impression that
state aid uh of the level playing field
issues
state aid had more or less been resolved
whereas standards
uh in particular how they would be
protected in future uh was outstanding
uh is just want to confirm that that's
the case
uh this morning philip lambert said
that he would prefer to see a sort of
one to two month continuation
of current arrangements if there was an
agreement
uh is that possible
and then a final question this may not
be for daniel
or you but it's about the five billion
brexit funds
in the budget how quickly can this be
activated i mean what
is uh there's i mean
the hardest um most difficult moments
for companies will be in i think you
know january february
adapting and facing problems supporters
etc so
you know can they
you know receive an immediate
reassurance from uh
the commission would they have to i
think that they would have to go through
their national government departments to
uh request some sort of access to the
fund
would it have its own mechanisms or
would it go through the solidarity fund
i mean
if just a little bit of the how it would
work
thank you dan and we'll see if balash
answers the last question yeah i
catherine i'll answer you on your first
two questions
um i think first of all yesterday after
the phone call the the president
uh stated that you know we're going to
continue negotiating
um on all topics but in particular on
fisheries but that does not exclude the
fact that there are other open questions
as well
um and there are open questions on the
on the level playing field
uh amongst other things of course but um
i cannot say
from here on the podium that x y or z is
is finalized or not
as the negotiations are um going as for
whether or not
the the transition period can be
extended i think i've explained
from the podium before that that is not
legally possible you know that there was
one possibility to extend the transition
period
and that was if you did so before the um
for the
month of june thank you
um let us
see if there are other questions before
then turning to balash on the brexit
fund
at the end of the sequence on on brexit
um please only keep your hand raised if
it is on brexit you'll see is your
question
on brexit if not on raise your hand
but if okay thank you uh griselda
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
here
thank you dan
indeed good afternoon a little update on
that front so what we call the brexit
adjustment reserve is indeed part of the
overall mff agreement which was by the
way struck yesterday
is one of the flexibility mechanisms
under the next mff
now what we know already is that the
overall size is 5
billion euro and the objective is of
course to counter
the adverse consequences of brexit and
to compensate the sectors which will be
hit the hardest by the departure of the
united kingdom from the european union
now in terms of the timeline we are
working hard on this piece of
legislation
it will come soon but at the moment i'm
not able to give you a
specific time thank you very much
so i passed the floor back to yossi
you'll see if you're still with us thank
you
yes you go ahead press speak
it seems you have an issue with your mic
source
as well once you try to sort that out
we will move to vaccines
and a question from thomas
yes thank you very much i hope you hear
me given that this is the
last midday briefing it's actually a
technical question for
for you i guess um on how do you plan to
communicate uh
next week okay the decision of ema is
going to be for the press department of
amer to
to communicate but then there is a
commission decision coming within two
days i understand and then there is the
the start of the vaccination day
um the 28th if i understand it correctly
so i was wondering whether you already
have uh
details about your uh communication
plans thank you very much
thank you thomas rest assured the midday
as you well know
is not the only channel through which we
communicate with the
with you and with the media more
generally and
of course we will be communicating
around
the different stages as they as they
develop
now it's christmas season uh there are
always christmas gifts and in terms of
communication i will ask you to
be patient um you will get
the communication arrangements as
as they are developed for the moment the
wrappings are being prepared
are there other questions for us on
vaccines today
raf if your question is on vaccines go
ahead
yes uh good day uh it is on vaccines and
it's a question on faiza there have been
you know reports about delays of uh of
delivery
of fisa and delays in time because of
that
and i just wanted uh how you at
commission are being kept informed of
that
uh what what you can do uh about that
and whether it's also
part of the contract that that you
should have speedy
and time set the deliveries of those
vaccines
thank you thank you i have a question
for stefan
thank you very much jeff yes of course
the commission is in contact with
uh the the different companies um
developing these vaccines
um to make sure that deliveries can be
arranged as you know uh
president fondling has announced that on
27 28 and 29
we would have our vaccination common
vaccination days
so we're working very hard to make sure
that we have
the deliveries of the vaccine so that we
can go ahead with such
vaccinations of course this is all
this all requires first that the
european medicine agency gives a
green light to the vaccine thank you
if you have a follow-up
yes please uh you know it's it's not
specifically about the
the first few days i mean this is a very
long-term effort to get everybody
vaccinated
and i was more worried about the delay
in delivery
over the next month or two months uh
that fizer
is facing and i wondered and then again
the same questions what can you do about
it
and and do we have any legal recourse
in that case thank you
thank you raf delivery schedules
delivery arrangements are
contractually laid down we are in
contact as i said with the company so i
don't think i can add
much more than what i said so it's
indeed not just a matter of insurance
deliveries
from the beginning but we have to make
sure that deliveries take place
in the ongoing months as well obviously
as far as this is concerned we have our
contractual arrangements
we remain in contact with the company
and we're all
working on that thank you
thank you stefan let's continue with
questions on
vaccines david
um
[Music]
um
um
um
see
okay we stay on the issue of
vaccines david
is your question on vaccines or on
health in general
go ahead yes on vaccines um i just
wonder if i could i could press this
question on the
on the pricing i've just never quite
understood
the public interest in the
confidentiality given
the global health stakes of this
particular procurement
process that it's not like any other uh
procurement process that we've seen
before
and so how is it if stefan could maybe
try and explain for
for in rudimentary terms for some of us
who are not perhaps
sophisticated enough to follow what is
the public interest that has been served
by confidentiality in this process where
the the demand
is so tipped in compared to a normal
process where you have businesses that
compete for a contract with with
government
uh the government you know controls the
shots here the government obviously
governments around the world want as
much vaccine as they can get so how is
it that the public interest is not
better served by transparency
where uh citizens journalists can
determine if there's reasonability
behind these prices i mean we're not
going to pretend
that this breach didn't occur we saw a
dramatic
range in prices from down just over one
dollar or one euro per dose
up to almost 20 per dose i don't know if
that's because moderna
is on the expensive end as a u.s company
and everything in the u.s
is expensive but let's please not be
naive in pretending that the numbers
aren't out there
but again getting back to the basics if
you could justify help us through
where is the public interest in this
transparency in this lack of
transparency
in the confidentiality understanding of
course that that doesn't change that it
may be legally required or contractually
required
but but where is the interest there
thank you
it's contractually required it's uh
that's i think you've answered the
question yourself we would not have had
those contracts
if uh there had not been that
confidentiality clause
inserted and by the way from what i
understand uh
you know this question is always asked
of us here in the european union but
from what i understand
the same applies to all the other
countries that have signed contracts on
on vaccines so we are simply in the same
situation
as as everybody else stefan do you have
anything to add to that
yes thank you yes i would like to add
that this confidentiality is in the
interest of the companies without any
doubt because it's
covering sensitive business information
but it's also indeed in the public
interest it's in the interest of the
negotiations
it's in the interest of the commission
the member states and
of the european citizens because we want
to reach fair agreements fair deals with
the different
companies if all the sensitive
information were to be made public this
would
weaken the position of the negotiators
of the commission the member states
involved in these negotiations in order
to avoid that
it is also important that
confidentiality
is respected thank you and let me remind
you david that as we've said here a
number of times
the fact is that the information on the
prices is available
to the member states who took part in
the negotiations
um on these on these contracts and that
mrs here yaquidas
has also made some statements as to
the efforts we would undertake to make
part of the information available
to the european parliament
other questions david you have a
follow-up
well i i just wish if um thank you first
of all to note that in fact the
confidentiality clauses are something
that the commission has agreed to so
they're not
just presumed to exist i mean it starts
to get circular in a way
but but stefan maybe if i could just
press you to again in in rudimentary
terms
you say it benefits the negotiation what
undermines
what in the in the in the process is
undermined
by having a sense of of what the pricing
is
out there in the public domain how does
that undermine how does that drive up
potentially the cost
for for governments i i just haven't
followed david i'm sorry
the economics behind i understand but we
are not going to get into this we have
answered everything that we can answer
on this issue there would not have been
contracts
if these clauses had uh had not existed
we we may regret it i understand that
but the fact is that a conditionality in
order to be able to
sign contracts to ensure
the delivery of these vaccines
was part of the negotiation so we might
as well not have had
any contracts and then we would not be
having this discussion i understand
fully and the commission understands
fully
the point that you're making about the
interest of
public publicizing the prices of
vaccines
and it is indeed a very relevant debate
we are not
questioning that whatsoever what we are
saying
is that this was part of the process to
conclude
these contracts and we are not in a
position
to change to change that uh that
situation and there's really nothing
that we can add to that
let us continue on the issue of vaccines
and vaccination more generally catherine
[Music]
position it's a giant market uh and it
can it has the market part you know
negotiate a good price but uh
president wonderland has always said
that this is a global issue you know
we're nobody's safe until everybody's
safe in a way
and i'm just wondering can will the eu
use its market power to help other
countries poorer countries
uh also get a better deal on the price
of these vaccines
thank you catherine i think we have um
explained
uh in quite some detail uh here on a
number of occasions
all the efforts that we are making um in
order
to ensure that poorer countries can have
um access to the to the vaccines
um in particular by organizing um
you know donations of surplus vaccines
um to third countries in particular in
our neighborhood
and through the kovacs facility
that is there to help precisely
purchase these vaccines it is in that
context that we are
that we are making the effort to help
countries that do not have the same
market powers we have
negotiate access to vaccines
let us stay on the issue of vaccines
you see i understand your question is on
something else
mosey if your question is on vaccines go
ahead
if this issue is covered by
confusionality i'm referring to the
question about
the number of doses which members will
start to receive now
after christmas concealing let's say
these production problems with fisa
can we expect that let's say the first
batches of doses will be distributed to
member states on a parata basis
because i think that's very important to
know for citizens in the member states
so they can
have an idea how these vaccination
programs will be
let's say developed or
in the coming months thank you thank you
steven
um thank you very much mosey as far as
the first batch is is uh concerned
uh on which we are concentrating our
efforts now in view of the
vaccination days of the 27 28 29th of
september
we are in contact obviously as has been
said a few times
with the company to ensure that we have
a sufficient number of doses that can be
shared with
or sent to the member states um
in general as i have already said in the
past as far as
the number of doses is concerned the eu
vaccine strategy
lays down a distribution key based on
the
population of numbers and this is
something this
which is the general principle which
applies to the delivery of
our vaccines thank you
thank you are there other questions for
us on vaccines
marines your question on vaccines
if so go ahead yes eric thank you yeah
thank you
um we saw the information from
commissioner varga that he today spoke
about
vaccine distribution on the western
balkans countries
but also now we have like breaking news
that after this meeting few of the
countries uh
in western balkans are very as they say
furious because
they been said that the no vaccines
through kovacs
will be available for western balkans
before
may can somebody confirm what was
the story during the today's talk on
this meeting and what will happen with
this kovacs and western balkans
distribution
thank you thank you i don't know if uh
anna can provide us with details
on um on the uh on the phone calls or
the contacts between
commissioner vahe and the western
balkans anna
um hi many thanks so i i'm very sorry
but i don't have a detailed readout
of what was discussed in in the in the
meeting you've seen commissioner's
tweets
um i think that our message uh from our
side is that you know as eddie very well
explained is that you know we are going
to work with our partners and with our
member states to be able to
um um to be able to facilitate some of
the uh
uh doses uh that will arrive in europe
also for our western balkans um we are
also
working for kovacs to help more broadly
um
in the rest of the world and uh specific
calendars uh uh for kovacs as to when
they can
uh uh do the the deployment of the
vaccines i think that's really for
kovacs
to explain um because of course they are
the ones that are negotiating as well
with the different producers um so i
would probably leave it at that
marina you have a
uh follow-up yes thank you just a short
follow-up um
uh obviously today there was a
mentioning about the 70 million
of euros as a help to western balkans
from european commission
uh regarding the the purchase of the
vaccines do you maybe have any
informations on this
i know
ana do you hear me
yeah yeah okay so um i cannot confirm
any figure for now marina but we are
working of course in also
uh making uh funds available from our
side that would of course uh help in
this joint effort with the member states
as well
to make sure that there are vaccines uh
that can be deployed in a timely manner
as commissioner has said
also for our western balkan partners as
regards to specific announcements in
terms of funding
you know that we would make them
available once there's a decision taken
in any case
thank you tommaso a question on vaccines
yes good morning thank you for the floor
of the tomato chronology it's just a
question about
the vaccine developed by fight sir
and bayern deck because if i'm not
mistaken i've right
that in the u.s the vials contain
not five doses that they should contain
but sometimes
six or even seven uh
is that because the u.s paid more for
the violence because according to the
prices which were published
by the end by the uh a belgian
secretary of state the you paid
12 euro per doses
thank you we have no comment tommaso and
you know it fully well
we're certainly not going to start
discussing the different contractor
arrangements signed
by the by the united states so we have
absolutely no comment to make
on the prices the quantities
of vials etc etc verna
my question is not on vaccines okay then
apologies
but um i will pass the floor again to
yossi who has been asking for the floor
for a long time
you'll see press speak do you hear me
yes we hear you go ahead yes okay uh
thank you uh my question is the
following
uh joselemkovic from european jewish
press the
european commission has said on many
occasions that it's
attached to freedom of religion i would
like to know how
does it receive the yesterday's ruling
by the european court of justice
upholding a ban on ritual slaughter
which is a as you know a very important
religious
practice for jews in europe thank you
thank you question for christian
[Music]
oh dear perhaps christian switch off
your camera
and let's do this
see if you can connect on the phone
so it does not it's not trying again
apologies for that okay
the commission take is not a court
ruling
um it will be for the referring belgian
court
to assess in light of the ruling the
justification in the
specific case of the flemish rule on
reversible
standing for ritual slaughter
let me make one thing very clear as you
put this in the context of of religious
freedom for the jewish communities
jewish communities are and always will
be
welcome in europe of course the
commission's respect
commission respects the judgment of the
european court of justice
as you said it's for the belgian
referring court to follow up in the
concrete case
um let me however point you to the words
of president thunderline in
in a speech which she gave just a few
days after she took office
where she said in the quote we are all
part
of the same community there would be no
european culture without a jewish
culture
and there would be no europe without
jewish people
fostering jewish life is something which
i have always taken
very seriously so we are committed to
fostering a
better understanding with and among
religious communities
including for open transparent and
regular dialogue between the eu
institutions
religious associations and
philosophically non
confessional organizations under the
so-called article 17
dialogue nothing can change or resolve
to always ensure that everyone in europe
has the right to freedom of religion
we will always uphold this fundamental
right
we remain of course open to discuss the
concerns
that we are aware of of the
jewish and muslim communities in this
context
thank you christian are there other
questions
on this uh on this issue nawab is your
question on this
yes uh i would like to ask you also
because this ruling
of the what also affects the muslim
communities
in all of europe so i have not
understood what is your position towards
this ruling
because this should also mean that there
will be a ban
on the ritual shorter it could be
possible
so please you can clarify your position
i'm sorry noah but i don't believe that
the court
ruling concerns a
ban but christian will be able to
specify that
but i have not heard that the court
ruling in luxembourg has anything to do
with the ban on on this
on this process it is
it is much more simply
a an analysis which is given an opinion
which is given to the belgian
court on the
flemish decree that sets a certain
number
of conditions on ritual slaughter
christian do you want to add anything do
you want to add anything yes well
i could probably add that a few more
more legal details
from the court as you're asking about
this from the court's ruling it can be
inferred that member states
can adopt stricter national rules on
slaughter aimed at ensuring more
extensive protection
of animals at the time of killing under
the condition that they adequately
consider
the requirements of the freedom of
religion as
is of course guaranteed by the charter
of fundamental rights
and show on the basis of scientific
evidence and societal concerns that such
stricter rules are necessary and
let me stress once more that we have
full understanding of the concerns
of the muslim and the jewish communities
brought by the judgment and that we
remain
as always open to discuss such concerns
with the jewish and muslim communities
thank you very much thank you very much
okay werner we
move to you
different issue uh africa general tan
chef included in his
opinion on polish judges yesterday also
a
quite interesting opinion on the
uh judgment by the german national court
on the pspp
action by the by the ecb
um saying among others that no national
court is allowed by the treaties to
overrule a court of justice judgment
and if uh the national court is of the
opinion that
um that european judgment contradicts
the the german as a
national this uh the national court
should to ask the the national
government to leave
um the eu among all this does the
commission have any
uh comment on this and more specifically
uh you know that uh president
thunderline in spring
announced that the commission will uh
open an infringe
an infringement proceeding against
germany on this
we didn't have to hear anything on that
anymore does the commission
still intend to to open an uh
infringement proceeding thank you
thank you christian
so everyone i didn't fully understand
the very beginning of your question so
on which which judgment were you
referring to if i may just ask you
clearly it was on an
opinion of the advocate january
related if i understand well to the pspp
program
of the of the ecb but in the context of
a different
uh of a different issue related to
polish judges
but the question concerns basically what
we are going to do about
the um about the
uh ruling by the uh court in council
yeah i think i think on the on on the
the ruling that you me or the opinion
that you mentioned
uh that would be a more more question
from martha but i'm happy to give you
the latest on
i mean and our position on the primacy
of you law which is of course
very clear the commission has constantly
affirmed
the primacy of eu law and that all
judgments
of the court of justice are binding on
all national courts i think we have said
this several times and the president
herself
was clear when saying that the final
word
is on you law is always spoken in
luxembourg the commission is in contact
with the german authorities to address
the issues raised
by the judgment of the german
constitutional court of 5 may
this year the commission has a strong
interest
to ensure that both the euro system and
the union court system can function
properly at all times and
that the ecb and the court
execute their respective mandates and
roles
as for seen in the treaty the commission
has not yet taken
a decision as to whether or not to open
an infringement procedure on the
concrete case
thank you i
see only one hand raised so we will move
uh to you tommaso
yes hi good afternoon eric thomas agency
i have a question is another topic
roughly two hours ago
commissioner han said that the italian
government submitted to the european
commission a draft
of the reforms that would be
financed through the recovery and
resilience facility
can you please confirm first of all if
you received or not
this document and considering
commissioner han referred to a draft
i assume it is confidential but i hope
not as confidential as the contract with
pfizer so i was hoping if you can tell
us
what are these reforms about thank you
okay
first a point of process tommaso as you
will understand
we are not here to infirm what
commissioners have said
you have a statement by commissioner han
this is uh this definitely stands on uh
uh further details uh i don't know if
marta can add anything
martha on the italian plan
thank you very much maybe a few words
indeed on on the process we are
currently in i mean as you know we have
been
in touch for quite some time now with
all the member states including italy of
course
on the preparations of the recovering
resilience plans you know those
stocks have obviously now intensified
very much um
but as you know it's also not the moment
for us now to comment on the details of
those plans because you know this is
subject to
to the ongoing discussions so um
and as you know of course now that the
political agreement on the rrf has been
reached
and we hope that the regulation will
enter four into force uh
very quickly member states will also be
able to submit
formally their plans so again those
plans are still
it's a work in progress so i would not
be able to provide you further comments
at this stage thank you
thank you other other questions for us
today
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
usb
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign